really appreciate you being out there
but it's very dangerous please be
careful
thank you very much we will briana
taylor's mother says her fight for
justice is not over after the city of
louisville agreed to pay
her family 12 million dollars
briana taylor as you know was shot and
killed in march when officers burst in
her home during a raid
now this is the most the city has ever
paid in a police misconduct case
demonstrations continued in louisville
last night in honor of taylor many
people still saying
say her name national correspondent
jerica duncan is there with more on the
story
jericho good morning to you what's next
in this case
good morning to you gail we're told that
the kentucky attorney general daniel
cameron actually empaneled a grand jury
to hear evidence against those officers
just days before
the announcement of this settlement it's
a settlement that includes
police reforms reforms that briana
taylor's mother says if
implemented much sooner could have saved
her daughter's life
today i felt like pressure was applied
brianna taylor's mother tamika palmer
and her two attorneys say the 12 million
dollar settlement
is just the beginning it was a president
said a settlement
to declare that black women lives matter
too
at tuesday's announcement louisville
mayor greg fischer
apologized i'm deeply deeply sorry for
brianna's death
and do you accept that apology i think
that
[Music]
it took him a while to get there there
is no admission at fault
12 million dollars plus reform says a
lot
those reforms include retaining social
workers to support and assist officers
overhauling search warrant procedures
and creating an early warning system to
better track officers who have a history
of complaints
brianna was a first responder here you
know during her time on earth
she helped people she saved lives and
and she's continuing to do that
her family and the attorneys are now
focused on the officers involved
in taylor's shooting death at a minimum
it should be second degree manslaughter
charges
back in march taylor and her boyfriend
kenneth walker were in bed in her
apartment
when police executed a no knock warrant
in connection with a drug case
walker fired one shot at police saying
he believed they were intruders
three officers returned fire killing
taylor
no drugs were ever found in her home
kentucky's attorney general daniel
cameron is leading the investigation
into the fatal shooting what would you
say to daniel cameron
today if he's watching even imagine if
it was your his child
i don't think what i've asked for has
been anything
other than what she deserves and it's
been justice from all along
steve romines is the attorney for
kenneth walker clearly the grand jury is
meeting now
when they return something or when
there's a report
you know what is wait and see as
louisville braces for a decision
regarding the fate of the officers
businesses remain boarded up throughout
downtown
as for palmer she says she's grateful
for the peaceful protesters
who continue to say her daughter's name
you've got these people who don't even
know you who are continuingly
to lift you up
one officer has been fired three others
were put
on administrative reassignment now
before this settlement the city did take
some actions they passed
brianna's law which bans no knock
warrants and it makes it mandatory for
police officers to wear body camera
videos
when carrying out or body cameras rather
when carrying out
a search and that did not happen in the
case of briana taylor
anthony all right jerica thank you even
though no one has been charged yet
as the family lawyer says 12 million
dollars in reforms
says a lot it does but it will never
replace what she's lost we all
understand that i was looking at the
beautiful picture brianna taylor back
there this story is not over
because so many people believe that
justice has not been served in this case
my heart aches from mrs palmer
but i am glad